actually I was born Terrence Thomas
kevin o'leary my dad was Irish and he
loved long names but when they got me
home everybody realized it was going to
be total confusion because dad was named
Terry too so the next thing I knew I was
Kevin
two years later my brother Shane came
along my dad was a gregarious Irishman
and a great salesman we had a happy
family
middle-class my parents worked hard but
then at the age of 37 Terry my dad died
leaving my mother georgette alone with
two young kids and times look tough and
then his life would have it things
changed my mother georgette met George
they fell in love and married she would
spend the rest of her life with this man
and George became my stepfather he was a
young man just graduating college at the
University of Illinois at
champaign-urbana and our whole family
moved there they were wonderful times
but we didn't know what the future would
hold
when George finally graduated he joined
the ILO part of the United Nations and
that's when things went wild we moved
everywhere we saw the world every two
years a brand new country we started in
Egypt France Japan then we lived in
Tunisia Ethiopia Cyprus Cambodia
Switzerland you name it I've been there
I didn't know it at the time but living
in all these places around the world and
actually seeing them had a profound
impact on me imagine living in Addis
Ababa the capital of Ethiopia at the
time of Halley Selassie and actually
seeing him long before he became a deity
of the rest of Aryans and playing with
his lion cubs or living in Phnom Penh
during the time of Prince II Anouk and
his lieutenant Paul Pott who would
eventually lead the Khmer Rouge and was
responsible for a genocide of his own
people during the horrific killing field
campaign in Cambodia these were
remarkable experiences for me and gave
me a unique firsthand education on how
the world really works now you can read
a research report on any place but
actually living and being there is a
whole different experience and gives you
a huge advantage as an investor today
some of my best returns are global when
I graduated from college with a degree
in environmental studies in psychology
my dad George said look you're going to
starve to death you're not gonna make
any money go back to business school
it was great advice that's exactly what
I did and when I graduated I started my
first company special event television
we made sports programming for Network
shows like Bobby Orr and the hockey
legends and the original six it all
worked out and when we sold the company
I took the proceeds and started softkey
software products later after we had
moved to Boston and turned it into the
Learning Company we sold it for 4.2
billion dollars it was a huge experience
for all of us that were involved and it
changed the way I looked at being an
entrepreneur forever today I believe if
you've been successful as an
entrepreneur you owe the next generation
a roadmap not just about your successes
but more importantly about your failures
to help them from not making the same
mistake I've authored three books about
money in business and luckily they've
all been bestsellers I got married to
Linda when we both had nothing we
couldn't afford a big wedding so we had
a reception on her apartment afterwards
and ordered in pizza for our guests it
was a fun wedding anyways and we were on
a journey if you're trying to build your
own business you make big sacrifices
when the kids came we had to work as a
team to keep it together today I try and
spend as much time with my family as I
can to make up for the early days when I
was not around I love to cook and I'm
passionate about O'Leary fine wines I'm
still taking pictures and I love to
collect guitars and oh yeah I love to
play them too like everybody else I want
to be a rock star when I grow up
I spent a lot of time teaching I tell
students you don't start a business out
of green it's not about money why do you
want to be an entrepreneur to set
yourself free the pursuit of
entrepreneurship is about freedom and
helping others achieve their goals at
the same time today I'm the chairman of
oh she shares exchange-traded funds I
travel the world for our investors
looking for opportunities it's a global
enterprise and I love my work people are
always asking why do you keep going and
here's my answer if you want to help
someone anyone anywhere in the world the
best thing you can do is create a job
for them who does that entrepreneurs
I'll spend the rest of my days
encouraging people to do exactly what I
have done become an entrepreneur start a
business and create jobs there is
absolutely nothing in the world more
important or noble than that